tonight joe biden continues his quest to
remake america
i want you to think about that just
about 60 days ago it was a cold clear
day in washington
joe biden moments after putting his hand
on the bible and reciting his oath of
office
said this today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together we have never
ever ever ever
failed in america well we've acted
together
his whole soul he said by his entire
speech was all about reaching across the
aisle and bringing
america together but now 64 days later
we know that what he said was a flat out
lie not only did he not mean what he
said in that speech
he never meant it by knew he was walking
into washington with the slight
majorities in both
chambers of congress radical agenda was
on his hit list though
if he had any interest in working with
republicans he would reach out to his
40-year friend the most powerful
republican
in the world in washington mitch
mcconnell how'd that go
i haven't been invited to the white
house so far this administration when
was the last time you had a conversation
with president biden
even on the phone
i don't believe i've spoken with him
since he was sworn in we had a couple of
conversations before then
is that any way to make a deal don't
talk to him you see
when your goal is overhauling america
you don't bother sitting down with the
opposition instead
according to axios president biden held
an undisclosed meeting in the east room
of the white house
with a group of historians to put his
transformational agenda into context
how big is too big he asked how fast is
too fast he asked historians made it
clear
speed matters size matters remember
promises are easy
keeping them is tough remember when
president obama said this
we are five days away from fundamentally
transforming the united states of
america
he tried but he didn't succeed president
biden's not just picking up where his
old boss left off
he is blowing obama's progressive agenda
out of the water i'm not kidding
look at what he's done so far 1.9
trillion stimulus chock full of state
subsidies and new entitlements
if your jaw is still on the ground keep
it there because he got a three trillion
dollar infrastructure plan all ready to
go
some say it's going to be 5 trillion
even though i held up
10 fingers just meaning 5. then he's
going to blow up the filibuster
something he's promised he'd never do
to solidify his democratic power base
with hr1 that's going to be a voting
thing
so what's after that attack the second
amendment that was yesterday
over regulate the energy industry that
was day one make d.c the 51st state
they're talking about that now
joe biden wants to change every aspect
of american life i'm not kidding the way
we travel the way we work where we're in
our businesses the way we vote the way
we educate our kids
for historical context we need to go
back to the 60s with lyndon johnson
and the 1930s with fdr
restoration calls however not
for changes in ethics alone
this nation is asking for action
and action now ours
is a time of change
rapid and fantastic change
bearing the secrets of nature
johnson's great society revamped health
care education welfare and civil rights
fdr's new deal
overhaul overhauled our infrastructure
and banking systems established things
like social security
biden's agenda will try to combine the
agendas of both presidents and go
further left than any administration has
gone before
remember when ronald reagan said
government is not the solution to the
problem
it is the problem well guess what joe
biden and big government
they have come here and it's now our
problem in every aspect of our life
with that let's turn to a man who also
knows joe biden well he's a senator from
south carolina lindsey graham senator
has president biden reached out to you
no i haven't talked to him before the
election but the problem with this whole
change america
is you got to change it for the better
not for the worse and look at what's
happening at the border
is changing for the worst because
president biden doesn't understand
what he's doing when it comes to the
border he's going to put vice president
harris in charge of cleaning up the mess
at the border
i'd gladly work with her but she doesn't
understand
what has generated this problem this is
not a trump problem this is a biden
problem
it's pretty hard to fix a problem if you
don't know what the problem is
so i think the republican party is going
to come roaring back
because this radical agenda will not go
down well with middle america but center
look
he's close to blowing up the filibuster
right now the 5 trillion
is in the hopper right now and he has
popularity over 50 percent
right now and he's got both seeds of
government
right now what makes you think the next
thing going down your throat because
he's not going to negotiate with you is
not going to be
an infrastructure package full of things
you never planned on things you never
planned on
it could be it could be but to change
the filibuster
uh it's not as easy as you think it is
there's a record
requirement in the senate don't want to
get too technical but you can't pass
anything in the senate unless you have
51 people show up
if they do this radical move to change
the senate
to make d.c estate to spend multiple
trillions of dollars on their liberal
wish list
we do have some power up here to fight
back and we will
but i think it's all going to come
undone around immigration
uh the president trump brought
order to chaos why do we have so many
unaccompanied minors coming to the
border
it's not because of seasonal changes joe
biden changed trump policy and it was
pretty simple
trump was going to send every
unaccompanied minor back to their home
country
check them for human rights abuse but
they're all going back home joe biden
said we will no longer deport
unaccompanied minors
and they're coming by the tens of
thousands trump said if you apply for
solemn you gotta wait in mexico to your
court date you can't be released in the
united states
the biden administration did away with
the remaining mexico
uh policy that trump had and by the
summer
there's going to be at least a million
people knocking on our door
at the border unless they reinstate
trump policies
we'll see if vice president harris can
figure this out well look uh
there's no sense uh of you don't have a
sense of what vice president harris
wants to do with the border you don't
have a sense what joe biden wants to do
at the border except blame trump and
those are
those words today you did have a
proposal today so you have a way of
solving the border problem
if people would tap into you you also
want to do overhaul
immigration but it was just yesterday
when they decided to go down and go to
guatemala new mexico
uh senator what's it going to take to
get to the central american countries
and even mexico
to get them to guard their own border
well you know trump did it trump got the
mexican army to deploy along
uh the southern border and by tens of
thousands
uh he he created a situation where in
the triangle countries you would apply
for asylum in your home countries
and these the northern triangle
countries work with trump because they
were afraid of him
he's willing to help the northern
triangle countries build their economy
but they got to help us with legal
immigration
i do know what harris thinks about the
border she wants to have open borders
she wants to provide illegal immigrants
for free health care
that's what she said when she's running
for president but it's one thing to run
for president and vice president and
this
is another thing to do the job the
mexican president
said that he blames joe biden for the
spike in illegal immigration
joe biden is blaming donald trump here's
what the american people have figured
out
that the border is deteriorating on
biden's watch because of the choices
biden has made
not being trump is the centerpiece of
biden's administration
when trump got it right it doesn't
matter they just don't want to be trump
i'm going to the border tomorrow with 18
senators
i'll make a prediction that immigration
will be a bigger issue in 2022
than it was in 2016. you have to go to
facilities where they don't choose to
show us video they're actually shooting
our own
video for us what a nice thing for the
government to do so you got to go to
donna texas where it's overrun
you have to go to places where they're
in pens maybe not cages but
in pens senator we always talk about the
double standard but this is as egregious
as it gets
when you talk about kids in cages there
are more kids than president trump had
on his watch
right now and they're broken up this is
a pandemic mind you
and they're not uh they're not exactly
treated in sanitary conditions but we
are writing
big checks for them to stay in hotels
and on military bases
well people are coming because the
policy now allows you to stay in the
united states
unaccompanied minors under the biden
policy can stay in america
there were 684 kids in a shelter built
for 80.
this is a nightmare along the border how
do you fix it go back to the trump
policy of telling every unaccompanied
minor in their family that if you come
to america
you're going to go back home you're not
going to stay here if you want to seek
asylum in this country you have to apply
outside of america you're not going to
be released inside the country
hoping that you'll show up four or five
years later for your court date
if you'll do those two things which my
bill does this will stop in about two
weeks if you don't do this it will never
stop
so i believe that the visit uh this this
weekend to the border
is going to be very important for the
country to understand
uh how these policies are failing this
will be the achilles heel
the undoing of the biden administration
will be their immigration policies
if they don't change course the
unscripted portion of being president is
something they're not ready for
whether you're falling downstairs or
have a uh i have a problem at the border
or russia opposed their ambassador that
was not in the plan
senator if there's a problem in
afghanistan you go and iraq you go in
syria gov there's problem with the
border you go
i wish more senators had your energy
appreciate it
thank you thank